On the last 20 years,
there have been great changes for people
with intellectual disabilities.
Many countries have passed laws that
open schools to children with
intellectual disabilities.
Uh,
it's hard to believe,
but just a few generations ago,
a few decades ago,
many children with disabilities were
never allowed to go to school.
School's were told,
uh,
what I would tell parents,
no,
there is no place in this school for
your child.
So schools have opened up in some
places.
Employers have begun to see a person
with an intellectual disability as
someone who can contribute,
someone who will be a loyal worker,
someone who will be a reliable worker,
someone who will help create a positive
environment at work.
So employers have begun a,
the long process of opening their doors
of opportunity to people with
intellectual disability and healthcare
institutions have begun to study,
uh,
the various forms of intellectual
disability and begun to respond with new
kinds of treatments,
new kinds of interventions,
new kinds of therapies that not only
help prevent those forms of intellectual
disability that are preventable,
but also,
and maybe more importantly add to the
quality of life of those who have an
intellectual disability and want to
contribute.
So changes have been positive in most
countries.
Do we still have work to do last?
Yes.
All the positive changes in employment
and healthcare community living
education are still unfortunately
isolated.
Examples,
most children with intellectual
disabilities never go to school more
than 90 percent,
never have a job.
Almost all of them never have real
friends.
Very few still ever get to play on a
sports team.
Ever get to join a community
organization.
Ever get to stand up in front of a crowd
and say,
look what I've done.
Look how well I've done.
Give me a chance at a metal.
Give me a chance at a cup,
give me a chance at success.
That experience is still tragically,
uh,
the rarest of experiences in the lives
of people with intellectual disabilities
and their families.
Our job is to change that.
Well,
the biggest barrier facing people with
intellectual disabilities in almost
every country in the world is fear and
misunderstanding.
Negative attitudes.
Uh,
people still believe that a child with
an intellectual disability is somehow
lesser.
And so they say to parents,
so I'm sorry,
you have such a child,
they say to the child,
either in words or nonverbally,
I'm so sorry that you're having to live
such a tragic life.
It couldn't be in many respects a
further thing from the truth,
but that bias translates into a lack of
healthcare because people think,
why bother giving healthcare to these
children?
It translates into a lack of special
educators because people think,
why bother with special education?
We have to train and educate other kids.
It translates into a lack of employment
because people think,
why bother hiring this person?
They'll never contributed anything.
The biggest barrier is the negative
attitude.
The,
uh,
the result of negative attitudes are
whole systems,
whole social structures that too
frequently say to a child with
intellectual disability,
you are not welcome.
Our job is to reverse those negative
attitudes and create communities that
say,
you are welcome.
Show me what you can do.
You can contribute to the life of this
community,
to the life of this country.
Well,
I think the CRC is sufficient as far as
it goes.
It's a piece of paper.
It's a document.
It's a government document.
The real question is not is the wording
right?
The real question is,
is the implementation right?
Where are the people where the armies of
citizens who will take the challenge of
the CRC and make it come to life?
The real urgency of now is not to have
signatures on the bottom of the page,
but to have people in communities who
are doing the work of overturning the
attitudes and ensuring that the rights
of the child with an intellectual
disability are protected.
Where the teachers who will understand
that the CRC is an invitation to them to
open their classrooms.
Where are the principles and the
educators who will see in the CRC a
challenge to them to make sure their
school has special educators and other
resources where the mayors and the
chiefs and the local officials who will
say to CRC as a challenge to my
community to become an,
an icon of acceptance,
to become the place where people want to
visit,
to see what it means to be inclusive.
This army where the parents,
the young people,
uh,
the religious leaders,
the civic leaders who themselves through
every little fiber of the,
of the community can begin to weave in
that there's a place for the person with
special needs in my church and my
synagogue in my temple,
in my school,
in my institution,
in my place of work,
in my home,
on my playground,
in my park.
When that happens,
the CRC will no longer be on paper.
It will be,
it will have come to life.
Uh,
that will be the measure of its success
in the moment of celebration.